foreign
[Music]
success in applying artificial
intelligence to Medical Imaging and we
often saw things that were amazing like
the AI could do things that humans
couldn't do it could do things faster
and we were continually impressed it's
being applied from the entire spectrum
of helping you know schedule exams more
efficiently for patients improve the
throughput you know patients once
they're on the table helping acquire
images more quickly and so there are
something like 150 Radiology Imaging AI
algorithms that are currently FDA
cleared so it's definitely becoming kind
of a critical part of radiology the AI
can be trained to look for things that a
radiologist just routinely would either
be very difficult for them to work
through or is not the main focus of why
they're reading that exam but the AI can
make sure that these things are not
getting overlooked but we also started
to notice in certain instances that the
AI would fail or give us unpredictable
or unexpected results
and we really wanted to investigate that
more and we came across a funding
opportunity announcement from the
National Library of Medicine that seemed
just right for the types of problems we
were starting to think about there's
kind of a cliche within AI that you can
build something and have it work
perfectly here but if you take it to the
hospital down the street it doesn't work
anywhere close to as well and so what
we're really after is getting AI that
can be applied almost anywhere with
equal results the other big problem is
that humans inherently tend to trust
computers maybe more than they should
but if a computer tells me hey I found
something in this image it's very likely
that I'm going to believe it and so a
lot of the sort of mistakes that are
made by a deep learning tool today even
in a research setting are often
reinforced simply because a human is
inclined to trust that and what we've
started to notice is that AI can be
somewhat fragile if it's given an
unexpected input it can give a very
unexpected output and sometimes these
are extremely catastrophic errors that
the AI can make and so really the whole
goal of our research is to understand
how can we investigate where AI is
fragile how can we essentially break it
so that we can understand how to fix it
and make it stronger but really it comes
down to the ability to take what is
theoretical research and apply it to
healthcare and improve the treatment
that we can provide patients
foreign